in this episode of cloud performance
outlets we take a look at app engine
scaling settings to optimize our
instance count when we find the right
trade-off stay tuned to find out in a
previous episode we helped the developer
of partly-cloudy image suite reduce her
instance count with some clever shifting
of workload from the server to the
client while this brilliant solution cut
the number of active app engine
instances significantly some folks have
pointed out that we really should have
adjusted the scaling values of the app
engine llamo file instead now in
complete honesty I've never actually
messed with any of these settings in
detail so I had no idea what they did
why they did it or why I should care
about that but that's what we do here on
cloud performance atlas we figure this
stuff out as such it was time to dig
into the scaling setting file and figure
out how they influence the instance
count of our tests now I made some nice
charts and things but before we get to
that I have to take a moment and talk
about how App Engine decides to start a
new instance I mean we can't really
start tweaking these settings unless we
know what we're touching so you app
engine serving algorithms are constantly
deciding on whether it's better to queue
up a request or spin up a new instance
this takes into account a significant
number of factors for this decision like
a request queue depth average queries
per second average request latency etc
etc but to make things more simple let's
focus on the four primary systems that
you can consider in your configuration
file which can directly impact the
decisions that App Engine makes about
spinning up new instances number one is
the number of concurrent requests per
instance number two how long a request
can sit in the work queue number three
if there's any resident instances
available and number four what type of
instances you're using in order to
understand how all of these things
played together I decided to run a
little stress test to see how many
instances we could spin up on the
default setting with four seconds of
static response time obviously this
isn't a real-world scenario now when we
throw a hundred threads of connections
at our application for about ten minutes
we end up with a beautiful graph like
the Google Cloud console has that looks
like this my completely unrealistic
scenario topped out at about a hundred
instances to handle my work the blue
line right there so we can start
tweaking some of the scaling settings
and see how that value responds let's
start with an easy one concurrent
requests in order to optimize
performance versus instance
you can control the max number of
connections you have per instance the
max concurrent request setting allows
you to control this value the default
for this is 8 which we saw a graph for
already I change to 80 and re ran the
test you can see that the number of
instances drops significantly from 100
to around 20 or so which is important
since this means my bill has been cut by
a significant amount as well
the trade-off here is straightforward
the higher the value the less number of
instances you need to spin up
connections however if you set it too
high then you're going to see latency
problems as your instance is strapped
for resources or it may cause new
instances to be spun up if you eclipse
the available memory of your machine
lowering this value can help you find
the sweet spot between the number of
connections per instance the resources
needed for your requests and the
resources for your particular instance
class so let's reset that back to
default and see what the pending latency
settings do see when a request comes in
app engines friends will place it in a
queue until an instance becomes
available to service the request if
there are no available instances waiting
around then App Engine has to make a
decision either it waits for one of the
instances become available or it starts
up a new instance the values of min max
pending latency directly control how the
scheduler will allow a request to wait
in this queue before spinning up new
instances the higher the min pending
latency value the longer a request will
wait in the queue before triggering a
new instance to be spawned changing this
from our default value of 30
milliseconds to 6 seconds we can see
that a number of instances generally
drop compared to our base use case it
looks like we're topping out at about 65
instances or so for this test now max
pending latency on the other hand is the
time after which App Engine must start a
new instance if a request has been
waiting this long setting this value to
4 seconds doesn't really see much change
in the total number of instances that
we're spawning but it might just be due
to the constant load that's being put on
the system I mean I'll it'll probably
change once the workloads become a
little bit more variable now all of
these settings so far have dealt with
the requests themselves but we haven't
really talked about giving more
resources to the instance it should be
no surprise to you that your App Engine
instances are running on some physical
piece of hardware somewhere in the world
and the slower the machine
the longer it takes to do heavy
workloads leaving requests in the
request queue for longer the trick here
is to request the least powerful machine
possible that handles your workload and
doesn't force new instances to be
created as a result the default for the
instance class variable is f1 so let's
test an F for instance and see how that
changes things up we can see that for
our particular workload changing this
from f1 to f4 didn't really do much to
the overall number of instances however
I'd expect that to change if we were
actually CPU or memory bound instead of
just sleeping for four seconds okay okay
so we've tweaked to each setting and we
have a clearer picture of what it does
and how it impacts our incidence count
so let's find the sweet spot this means
that for our four second block of work
we want the average latency for a
response to be as close to four seconds
as possible to do this let's set
instance class to f4 max concurrent
request to 80 max pending latency to
eight seconds and min pending latency to
six seconds the result gives us about 18
instances through our test and only
about 400 milliseconds latency being
added to each request on average now
from here we can start tweaking these
settings to make trade-offs between the
number of instances we're willing to pay
for and the latency overhead it causes
for our users which is exactly the spot
that we want to be in however this won't
solve all of your performance problems
in the cloud that's why you should check
out the rest of the cloud performance
Atlas videos and remember then when it
comes to your users every millisecond
counts